today we're gonna be doing a night mode
test on the pixel 3a and the new iPhone
11 Pro max as soon as I heard that the
new iPhone 11 has night mode this is a
test that I knew I wanted to do so I've
got this really cool rig is that a Lord
of the Rings joke Gandalf from Lord of
the Ring I've still received certain of
the Rings or Harry Potter well okay
let's go get some photos supercool
all right be on auto engage
[Music]
Wow he's both really good okay I'm gonna
tell me where I should go Jen
[Music]
whoa I look cool I could always change
okay let's move on
yeah me this okay the first border that
I'm taking is I'm gonna set this to the
max exposure so it's gonna be eight
seconds
[Music]
yeah you can't even see her she's gone
he's just like this thief in the night
[Music]
okay let's go somewhere else we've got a
little water fountain here let's see
what this looks like this is really not
that great of a photo the pixel
definitely makes everything a lot more
colder whereas the iPhone I feel like is
a little more of like the natural type
of light and what they were mostly
saying is they wanted it to feel like he
wasn't talking about the elements and it
was more natural colors whereas the
pixel that's a little more neon inch
although I do like this is gonna be a
really cool shot hey there's hardly any
light over here
so I'm gonna turn the exposure up all
the way
[Music]
I'm super impressed he need those look
like really good photos that's the
problem when you're doing a comparison
like if I just saw this when you look
well that's incredible and if I just saw
this one by self wow that's incredible
but then we can get them both together
you're like wow okay let me just pick
this bottle apart like yeah pletely dark
it's so dark
that's cool okay well maybe it'll be
here there's a lot of like you're
actually wow you look like a demon this
looks cool you look cool all right
there's a lot of light here though
yeah hold on wait they keep will
whooshes hold on hold on ready
do not move starting no
[Music]
so it's cool with the iPhone is it does
show you the rest of the frame so this
is what you actually would be taking a
picture of but if I wanted to zoom in or
zoom out I'll show you that whole frame
okay your view can move sorry definitely
not okay
come on our best work okay we need
darker should we go down to the beach I
think that's a good try should try that
a good try it's a good try okay we're
gonna try to get this shot really quick
oh my god I look so cool oh I'm so hyped
about it setting it to max five seconds
[Music]
these look great make the fact that we
getting this type of what find more
darkness
Tyler's using his phone light because it
is so dark here that there's no way you
guys can even see me at all alright
let's get this job okay Wow Wow holy
moly you guys this is insane okay show
them how dark this is this is so insane
we need it my darker darker I don't even
have a weapon right now
so do we miss the balloon I think we did
all right
seems this looks like
tell there's crime down there careful
alright ready says move back to improve
focus the pixel is struggling right now
on this that's crazy
28 seconds the pixel did not even manage
to focus at all we're gonna try this
again no okay it focus so that's good oh
that looks pretty good actually
alright I'm gonna go back to the iPhone
we're gonna do a little less exposure
because that was kind of aggressive
we'll do five seconds
that's a lot better Wow Wow I'm so
impressed
hey there's a Google Sites Photoshop and
they both look very good yeah but this
is crazy
great that's just wait black yeah it's
in soon it's really crazy I'm impressed
actually could be cool I'd like to get
it maybe a shot of myself
whatever you say
I like that okay ready
[Music]
oh I'm into it they're both like two
different looks I would like to do a
shot Jen right here looking down and
then maybe flash a little light at me so
dark down here
okay that might even be too long but
we'll see well maybe not
I look like I've got a bum pose I
thought you wouldn't be able to see me
as much
so I've messed up because you can see me
quite a lot that's cool though you're
like leaning a little shot I love it oh
man this is so crazy looks so good ahh
this video was so much fun I hope you
guys enjoyed it I would love to know
from you in the comments below which
photos for your favorite and which phone
do you think looks better maybe not look
better but which ones did you prefer
more because I think they honestly
looked they both did such a good job and
now I'm gonna go I think to bed because
it's so dark out here where is my
channel gone Oh
[Music]